[Music]
when it comes to twitch i have this
routine of spending the first few
minutes surfing around
seeing who's streaming and deciding what
kind of vibe i want to be a part of
good morning good evening good afternoon
thanks for being here guys i appreciate
you
in a crucial part of twitch's appeal is
that ability to jump from personality to
personality and to be comforted by
routine
or surprised by something new and fresh
today
a bird flew into my window and died then
i took my ice cream and i sat there and
cried
and man was i surprised when on a random
sunday in september
i threw on pokemane expecting well
pokeyman
and while a version of pokemane was
certainly streaming
it was not a version i was expecting at
all a version that sent me down a rabbit
hole to a community i barely knew
anything about v-tubing have confidence
no confidence
so yeah pokeyman recently showed off a v
tuber model of herself
which she intends to use on days that
she just doesn't feel like being on
camera
so nice to almost be able to reinvent
yourself online and have a great
time i think that kind of thing is
appealing
to just just about anyone um and this
seems like
literally just taking that but to the
next level and almost immediately
there was backlash sure there was the
general irrational anger
that pops up whenever pokemane does
anything but more specifically
it seemed to divide the v tuber
community some v tubers claimed that she
was just cashing in on a trend that
smaller creators helped build
but others openly welcomed her into the
community seeing her participation as a
good thing
and one v tuber named sarah who i spoke
to for this video
wondered why anyone was upset in the
first place i think really it's just
pokey has a little bit of like drama in
her past
and people just want to hate pokey for
pokey and it was
less so the v tuber thing cerro says
that in her experience this negative
response to pokeman being a v
tuber isn't actually accurate to the
scene most vtubers are actually pretty
welcoming
and want nothing more than the scene to
grow according to saro
not only has pokeman's model been in the
works for a while
but she even replaced the artist's
computer when it randomly died
similar to pokemane using her v tuber
model when she just doesn't want to
appear on camera
it's not uncommon for people to use v
tubing as a way to take the pressure or
sometimes objectifying nature of
streaming off of them
while also creating work that they
typically wouldn't make and v tubing has
caught on with popular streamers like
lily pichu who also just had a model
created for her
and then there's miz kiff with whatever
the hell he's doing
[Music]
hi but here's the thing
v-tubing has existed in one form or
another
for decades at this point so let's
rewind and explain how the hell we got
here
now we got to make a quick stop in 1961
when a technology called speech
synthesis was pioneered which back then
was basically a rudimentary form of
text-to-speech singing
[Music]
fast forward to 2004 and something
called
vocaloids were created and as a
predecessor to v tubers
vocaloids are 2d and 3d rendered models
who can sing and perform
using a version of speech synthesis
technology they were and still
are insanely popular
[Music]
now the v tuber community of today
originated in japan
and at its core being a v tuber combines
a culture that values anonymity and
privacy
with emerging technologies see in japan
it's not unusual for musicians or
performers to wear masks on stage in
order to protect their identity
even certain social media platforms
encourage users to remain anonymous
online
it's definitely like a huge thing um the
anonymous factor in the community like
it's something that everyone is very
respectful of like it's very
frowned upon um for
people to try to like figure out uh
someone's actual identity like behind
their avatar combine advances in body
tracking software throughout the 2010s
and a proliferation of social media
platforms with an ingrained philosophy
of maintaining anonymity online
and a collision course almost seemed
inevitable enter kazunai
[Music]
bursting onto the scene in 2016 kazuna
claims to be the first ever v
tuber and despite implying to her
audience that she's some sort of
artificial intelligence
she's actually fully voiced by a
japanese actress
her almost 3 million youtube subscribers
follow along as she plays video games
draws random stuff
and chats with her fans she's become so
popular that the japanese government
even made her an official ambassador for
tourism
on top of that she's appeared in a
variety of different commercials
anime tv shows and even hosted a variety
show called kazunai
no beat scramble fast forward a few
years and the v tuber community has
exploded
according to hypersense a face tracking
technology company and research firm
there are thousands of different virtual
celebrity and be tuber accounts
on youtube sitting alongside kazunai in
terms of popularity are models like
kaguya luna and mirai akari together
they create this kind of trifecta of v
tuber insanity with all three frequently
showing up in each other's videos
and of course due to popularity even
talent agencies have emerged
one of the biggest ones hololive has
dozens of channels and personalities
signed to its roster while an agency
like hololive might represent a more
corporate shift for some of the v tubing
community using a model or an avatar is
a form of creative expression
it's the ability to role play as someone
other than yourself
and the creative design of these models
are often personal relating back to an
aspect of the person
behind the screen it's only natural for
v tubers to be protective about their
craft's sudden explosion and popularity
among people who showed
no interest in it a few months ago but
the thing is
streamers like pokemane aren't really a
threat to the legitimacy or longevity of
v
tubing if anything she's helping to
introduce people to something that
they might actually become passionate
about the biggest thing that i took away
from jumping down this rabbit hole
isn't that v tubing is weird or is
something to scoff at
[ __ ] at one point watching twitch at all
was weird v tubing has become another
vibe
another opportunity to feel comfortable
and ultimately
it's another community for people to
enjoy being a part of
and even though i discovered that the
world of v tubing is actually really
cool
at the end of the day i've decided it's
just not for me
alex what the [ __ ]
you